look at this all those years in the big  city we finally got out we're living the  dream maybe it is a dream  [Music]  then everything just blew up big flash  like a pink light or actually I don't  even know what color it was it wasn't  like any color I'd ever seen before  looks like a meteorite  he's radioactive I mean it's her face  right meteorites are Germany no more  dangerous than ordinary L'Occitane okay  so do they just disappear did you plant  those no wart here for a sec oh god  who's talking to you it's in the stat he  gets into moisture sin here is out there  that's out there is in here now  everything's under control here you know  in denial that demons from the meteorite  changes everything around it  [Music]  it's just good color  can you believe me now I don't know why  I believe anymore  [Applause]  [Music]  everything's gonna be a-okay  you